today on our show once you go black you
never go back
that's right we were gonna watch the
Black Panther Gigi during the NBA files
we're gonna watch it we haven't seen it
virgin eyes look at these eyes they
don't get laid new urgent eyes and we're
gonna watch this trailer in front of you
for the first time right now on fat man
on Batman's welcome to fat man back now
I'm Kevin Smith I am a king what kind of
yes I'm Bernard Marx what Marx trying to
communicate is it's a big day for all
comic book fans but for some comic book
fans an even bigger day when why it is
the biggest game because Blaine why
because today today Friday June 9th
during game for the NBA Finals Marvel
decided you know we're going to do we're
going to drop the first teaser for Black
Panther which you know I got a theory my
man and good happen for DC movie Marvel
very quickly comes around and tries to
put it out with a urine for urine it's
flame to douse the flames with the
stream of urine I'm always trying to
piss on DC's good time just as Wonder
Woman's enjoying like insane box-office
number one movie last week over 100
million highest-grossing film ever
directed by a woman like just all these
a record-breaking run suddenly for no
good reason other than like [ __ ]
Friday Marvel decides to suddenly drop a
trailer for a movie that it's what ten
months nine months away next year I mean
okay listen
in this fight between Marvel and DC we
all win but this is more gentlemanly
than it could have been like ice they
gave him a couple of weeks because they
could have done this the Friday Wonder
Woman hope it's true it was ready it's
not like this the ink is dry and it
would have been it would have been
Wakanda versus to the spirit which is
your side but huge for those of us who
grew up in the 70s reading comics you
never imagined you'd see a Black Panther
movie but
of us who love do the right thing one of
their favorite moments in the movie is
Black Panther II pizza we pizza believe
one of the characters literally carried
on Black Panther comic the whole the
whole movie do the right thing it's a
big deal but I'm a white guy you're a
white guy take over mark as I white guy
at heart but as I said during the wonder
1 review I completely understand why
women are losing their [ __ ] over this
when Black Panther comes out I'm going
to be a puddle of [ __ ] tears and I'm
not sure what's gonna happen under watch
this trailer cause we haven't seen it
yet but I'm already getting a little
glisteny on a very special episode of
fat man I'm Batman you may see mark cry
I will be the one crying you know how
it's like sometimes they put the trailer
big and little on the screen we're gonna
go big so you can watch mark side
[ __ ] as they get clammy at 7:00
big day for all kyle book fans in
general as well we're about to look at
Black Panther we've seen the debut of
the character in Civil War played by
Chadwick Boseman deep metal drop the
poster today in advance which looks
phenomenal huh it's a big throne big man
T'Challa coming it's with a date that
you're like why but again I bet your
Valentine's Day make you more luminous
footage it is about those they move yeah
James love so here we go man further ado
oh space Bart
she's back all right okay I'm gonna move
this thing down so make sure her view is
uninterrupted when we go the volume is
up here we go folks you're going to
watch us watch the Black Panther and in
3 a 2 A 1 light blue circuit
[Music]
folks relative
[Music]
first impressions ah it's like what I've
coming to America had balls yeah we're
done instantly I was like coming to
America as well yeah no I love the idea
that that makanda exists beyond some
veil of mystery like in its Eldorado of
legend of Maryland almost Shambala yeah
absolutely
um number lot yes shangri-la Shambhala
is that as Shambhala is a dr. strange
right
and then what is dragon iron fist again
shangri-la no that's uh couldn't cook
them do Kunlun in London not condemned
that was a Martin Scorsese movie yes the
Klan um Michael B Jordan [ __ ] bad-ass
even pot he's a bad guy right seems to
be the bad guy not a ton of Chadwick
Boseman
I mean I feel like not that they're
hiding him but a little bit of we got
some black panther actually got a ton of
black panther action you got some of
these a frequent auto-ship I was like oh
damn
is that Lapita Nyong'o that's Dena one
of his guards I think the PETA is one of
his guards and Danai gurira from Walking
Dead Michonne is Shawn's one of the
guards yeah that's crazy [ __ ] nuts
I'd no idea this is this is going to be
like the all-star det amazing [ __ ]
mouth movie let's take another look and
dive deep man all right here we go
and this will have the best soundtrack
of any mobile movie ever will queued up
so claw was in Ultron mm-hmm ulysses
klaw what's the other dudes am that's a
guy I mean you know Martin what he's in
yeah Martin Larne frame difference he
was also in the civil doors
search for it called it El Dorado
there's misfortune South America statue
is on is that I'm the only one and they
doubt a lot oh that sounds awful good
[ __ ] your gun oh my god that is Michonne
right there I was talking but remember
the other secrets we see fighting in
hockey
[Music]
ha
the card sort of good man to be a pair
Art's a good man to be a chance that's
awesome
[Applause]
hmm step into the spotlight black no
little PS on the trailer and yeah I mean
it's an early one stand honestly like
that's more than we deserved an hour and
power minutes and 53 seconds that's
almost a full travel trailer and let's
not forget this first aired during the
NBA Finals which costs almost as much as
a Super Bowl they've been doing well
this is Sony no this is a Disney yes
Sony's been doing like spider-man
commercial ad nauseam including
spider-man the only reason I watch
[ __ ] best well I only know this
because on all the trailer channels on
YouTube they keep putting up new Home
Coming spots and you're like what's this
and some are game specific like it looks
like they shot them as you know game
boosters they're also right like you
know Spidey going to get snacks for Tony
Stark
yeah like and but but they're shooting
it's not like oh it's a cartoon
it's Robert Downey jr. and Tom Mullen
and Jon Favreau doing a commercial with
me please good and be a prick and you
get a little bit of extra footage and
then they show and then they say like
homecoming coming soon I mean it's
awesome I'm doing a bunch but this is
Disney going like I like Disney owns ABC
which is airing the finals so like
you're just moving money from one room
to another and also so smart for them
I'm sure they were just like look NBA
Finals getting ratings but you know what
boost it up a little what do you got
models like we got this could a big a
big black panther yeah did not I mean
the world looks big which is what you
want to feel like you want to feel like
you know what conduct should have the
same scope and size like Asgard does and
I'm going to feel like it does they have
the nice mixture of like a little bit of
the tribal ceremonial plus technological
advance plates on the flippin car look
like not American plates no so clearly
this is a not taking place I mean I it
would not surprise me on all of them
none of this took place in the States
right like I mean at the end of the day
we just watched guardians of galaxy come
nowhere near Earth so it feels like you
get away to a Condon story right away
with not really coming to
to stateside did they come stateside the
civil war they fought on an airstrip in
Germany that were that was supposed to
be I mean yeah that's that's in Germany
there's a bit in like oh us not looking
he was at the UN where his dad get right
killed so they have been to America
although I don't get the feeling that
that was in the US
I think that there was some other
diplomatic blah blah blah overseas I
think there in the u.s. to go to Queens
and get spider-man I think you're right
and I think there's a little bit in like
Avengers mansion in upstate may be so
Black Panther as far as we know hasn't
come to America I mean worse ya know it
doesn't look like it's gonna happen in
this movie and obviously y-yeah okay
haha but it's Martin Freeman's
characters name he's from the comics
it's a little kid caracal thing I don't
know but he's that guy's contact right
like that and we they set him up in
civil war
it looks dope man is directed by Ryan
Ryan Coogler who did Creed which is one
of my favorite movies of what last year
the year it came out amazing yeah
amazing [ __ ] like that's a movie way
if you're feeling like you're having a
little bit too emotional e.q even keel
of a day just watch the last act and
just [ __ ] all the tears like Stallone
habit is cancer bout [ __ ] Adonis what
your come on is it's what I'm getting
the ring the [ __ ] bill conti comes
into the last round also Fruitvale
station another wonderful yeah - but
Creed for our crews amazing flick this
you put this story this material in the
hands we gotta make creed you got my
money and look we've already seen a
minute and 53 seconds looks dynamite
looks lush it looks lush one of my
favorite things that I realized this
past week is that on the Disney lot in
adjoining editing Suites Ryan Coogler is
editing Black Panther Ava Duvernay is
evident regular and I'm like these two
giant [ __ ] fantasy franchises on a
studio lot with two african-american
directors working on them who can walk
back and forth and just talk about [ __ ]
like Ava's been tweeting she's been
watching how black man has been put
together for the last couple of months
sweetie it's so sweet it's so sweet and
just like that's the world we live in
now where there is not a bear
here anymore and for this kind of thing
where Ava can make 120 million dollar
movie and that's cool where patty
Jenkins can make a movie that's made 300
million dollars worldwide has crusting
towards 5 well Ryan Coogler can take a
stab at the first four serious like
Marvel Cinematic Universe black
character to get his own movie and knock
it out of the park like we live in
wondrous times my friend what won't we
see in the next panel what else is
possible I'll tell you what we won't see
is an Uncle Ben's standalone movie where
the great power cut up band Black
Panthers coming everybody next tribe you
cannot [ __ ] wait my favorite part
those done firing guns and you hearing -
ting ting ting ting and usually in the
vibranium nonplussed
to say the least good there it is man
for Batman I'm Batman Kevin Smith 9 more
not come back next episode same bat-time
same bat-channel smokers calm or
you-tube they're calm / Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]